scheiße hier sind ja auch elektrogeräte
vorsichtig hey leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut die
haben heute was wirklich cool ist vor
ich habe das oft in den kommentaren
gelesen dass ich das doch bitte
unbedingt mal wieder machen soll ich
habe ja vorher gut ein paar monate ist
das schon her da habe ich diese videos
gemacht ich teste zehn kostenlose
produkte da gab es bestimmt 4 part von
und ich hab mal wieder einiges bestellt
diesmal allerdings alles ein euro
produkte also ein bisschen was anderes
aber im endeffekt kommt es aufs gleiche
hinaus
ich muss sagen mit rich bin ich zurzeit
auf jeden fall nicht so weil irgendwie
verwirrt mich das alles manche sachen
kommen halt einfach nicht und hier diese
ganzen einen eure produkte ich kann euch
das gern hier mal ein blendend dasteht
bei keinem einzigen produkt hier nie
etwas angekommen ist allerdings habe ich
halt ich weiß nicht was du sonst sein
soll daher gut ich würde sagen wir lava
nicht lange und starten direkt mal rein
ihr seht hier liegen einige sachen rum
womit fangen wir an
fangen wir mal hier mit an ohne musik
box für 1 euro habe ich dir wirklich
bestellt alter gebt euch das mal hier
sogar nur 12 cent gerade
unwahrscheinlich 2 3 euro versand ich
bin aber gespannt das ist auf jeden fall
die günstigste musikbox die ich je
besitzen durfte deswegen weil die maus
oder alter was ist das denn
also sieht halt auf der verpackung so
aus als wäre die von der qualität her
gar nicht mal so schlecht wie also diese
musikboxen die man kennt so ein bisschen
hartgummi ist das ja glaub ich ne aber
was das jetzt weiß ich nicht er hört ja
wahrscheinlich dass ich denke mal der
sound wird klingen wie damals an die
ältere generation kennt ihr noch bei
mcdonald's da gab es immer auch so zum
happy meal so kleine musikboxen wir dann
halt immer ein nie drauf war
so wird sich das wahrscheinlich anhören
aber vielleicht überrascht es mich ja
wir machen das man geht nicht rein leer
zu sein aber kein problem
jetzt leuchtet hier auf jeden fall was
macht man es mal an ich sehe gerade die
gibt es in ganz vielen verschiedenen
farben ich habe hier mal grün ausgewählt
und jetzt konnten wir die macht die
macht jetzt schon so leise komische
geräusche also wirklich gut finde ich
das nicht aber
[Musik]
naja immerhin muss ich mir keine
gedanken machen dass das video nicht
monetarisiert werden kann weil die musik
die hier rauskommt so schlecht ist dass
dieses youtube system das ähnlich
erkennen wird aber ich sag mal so für 12
cent mit bisschen versand noch in
ordnung da kann man jetzt auch nicht
mehr erwarten aber an sich würde ich
raten bat dann die waren kauft euch eine
box die so 20 oder 30 euro kostet weil
das hier ist glaube ich mich so das
beste
naja immerhin noch nicht ausprobiert und
jetzt machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt was ist das denn alter berichten
hier bestellt das ist wirklich extrem
cool aus es handelt sich hierbei um
neongrün leuchtendes klebeband was halt
im dunkeln leuchtet das heißt wenn ich
da jetzt gleich an meine wand seinen
streifen hin klebe und das licht
ausmachen leuchtet das frage ist ob das
wirklich funktioniert aber ich denke
schon also darunter ein normaler oder
sagt kaum einer geht noch
also hier steht in der beschreibung dass
es auf jeden fall sobald das licht aus
ist leuchtet dann würde ich sagen wir
machen einfach mal das licht aus bitte
irgendwie sehe ich jetzt gar nichts mehr
also ein bisschen leuchtet das
vielleicht ich strahle das mal kurz
einmal mit dem handy an
vielleicht muss ich das ja auch erst so
aufladen oder so also ich hoffe ihr
könnt das ein bisschen sehen es leuchtet
so ganz leicht aber so wie das auf den
bildern außer ist es halt auf keinen
fall deswegen bisschen lärm so machen
wir das licht mal wieder an
ich lass das jetzt mal kleben und zeigt
euch das vielleicht am ende nochmal
allerdings bis jetzt bin ich ein
bisschen enttäuscht egal machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten
als nächstes haben wir hier um ein gott
ja der ja das ist absolut geil habe ich
auch für einen euro gekauft das weiß ich
ganz genau nicht auseinanderfallen wer
von euch
er rät jetzt schon was ist denn jetzt
wird abgebrochen so das ist
wahrscheinlich da muss ich sagen dass
ich feiere ich mein pizzaschneider ist
er mich auf mysteriöse art und weise
verschwunden und ich habe mir hier in
einem neuen bestellt als motorrad fand
ich übelst nice und das fühlt sich an
sich auch scharf an und dann kanns halt
hier so abstellen lustiges teil falls
ich jetzt heute oder morgen pizza
schneide will ich das einmal kurz
aufnehmen ob der wirklich gut ist damit
ihr das
einmal sehen könnt falls nicht lerne ich
euch hier irgendwie ein video ein von
irgendwem da die das benutzt
[Musik]
wir können dann kurz einen härtetest
machen ob das auch stabile na also das
hält auf jeden fall geil okay das war
jetzt mal ein geiles produkt wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten und das ist
keine ahnung welches aber ich werde es
gleich erfahren
ok hier haben wir also ich muss schon
sagen der erste eindruck von den
produkten ist immer gut man denkt sich
so ok das sieht wie ich weiß nämlich
jetzt was es ist das ist zwar ein
bisschen verbeult aber ich bin mal
gespannt ob mich das überzeugt sagt ich
guck mal kurz rein in welcher farbe ich
das bestellt habe weil die meisten von
euch werden sicherlich jetzt noch keine
ahnung haben was das ist hier haben wir
eine sensor neonlampen das heißt sie
steckst du ein zum beispiel nachts wenn
du auf tour bist kannst du diese eine
steckdose stecken und dann musst du
nicht das haupt licht anmachen sondern
gehst halt ins bad und dann geht immer
dieses licht an ich meine ich habe die
in pink bestellt ich hab den weiß
bestellt keine ahnung hätte wir testen
ist einfach ich mach das mal kurz
wirklich im bad steckt dass eine
steckdose
wir sehen uns da leute also ich habe das
jetzt mal eingesteckt das jetzt passiert
da nichts dabei kann sein dass im
dunkeln funktioniert dann kannst du
wirklich ein bisschen zu sehen
du hast wohl auf klo ging also was
reagiert halt sozusagen auf licht glaube
ich guck mal hier dunkler ist wird das
duell wird dass ich meine es wieder
heller tag aus okay leute willkommen
zurück wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt okay da habe ich mich
wirklich die ganze zeit schon gefragt
was das sein soll weil es ist halt
irgendwie von der form her nichts an das
ich mich erinnern kann hat jedoch auch
jetzt hier
was ist das denn 100 prozent made with
wedding
das kann ich nur noch meine zähne machen
habe ich das wirklich bestellt manchmal
ist das ja so dann gehst du dadurch und
alles was ein euro kostete rein aber
hinterfragt gar nicht okay will ich das
wirklich test gebt euch mal hier das
foto das produktbild davon
ich glaubs auch als wenn die jungen das
ist ja so dumm ich mach das mal auf
meiner hand hier schmeckt eigentlich
ganz gut nach orangen aber
wahrscheinlich youtuber stirbt weil er
von wish zähne bleaching probiert hat
also könnte sein leute ich muss
irgendwie sagen meine zähne sind
eigentlich weiß ich weiß nicht warum ich
das bestellt habe ich muss das jetzt
nicht unbedingt ausprobieren also wenn
jetzt in den kommentaren die ganze zeit
steht alex teste dass man zeigt uns ein
vorher nachher ich will euch auch nicht
so meine zähne von namen zeigen ist ein
bisschen eklig aber erstmal muss ich mir
auch dazu noch irgendwelche rezensionen
durchlesen ob das wirklich nicht
schädlich ist oder so weil gesundheit
geht immer vor
und ich habe da dann schon ein bisschen
bedenken naja gut gar kein problem wir
haben ja welche als nächstes habe ich
hier das gibt ja okay was ist das denn
neulich hab wieder keinen plan was ich
hier bestellt hat
was soll das sein jetzt weiß ich es ist
ein mini gps gerät für euer haustier
man kann das dann so praktisch hier fest
machen und dann immer gucken wo sich das
haustier befindet oder hier auch auf dem
foto wird gezeigt natürlich auch für
babys benutzt war das heißt wenn euer
baby immer weg gabelt könnt ihr den baby
so ein ding im hals hängen und dann seht
ihr mal wo sich das baby befindet
das hier wirklich mit seinem baby
geworben wird ist schon wieder richtig
typisch naja durch braucht dafür ja
vermutlich auch eine app merching nennt
sich die app dann würde ich sagen
download ich die mir mal und wir schauen
ob das wirklich funktioniert das lässt
sich dann gleich aber unten deswegen
sehen wir uns jetzt unten wieder
also leute ich habe das gerät jetzt hier
mal verbunden und mit dieser app
heruntergeladen jetzt kann man zum
beispiel hier diesen alarm auslösen
und hier hat man noch die map wo sich
das gerät befindet ich weiß noch nicht
ob das irgendwie wenn wenn das jetzt
zwei kilometer weit weg ist glaube ich
nicht dass man das hier noch worten kann
weil das ist auf jeden fall jetzt nur
via youtube verbunden können wir
trotzdem ab
leute das hier ist das nächste produkt
ich weiß nun ein gott ein riesen
luftballon oder was war das noch mal
alter 1 36 zoll aufblasbarer hüpfball
das heißt da kannst du wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen wasser einfüllen und ihm
dann aufblasen
das machen wir da habe ich sogar auf das
habe ich so ewig nicht gemacht ich will
dir erstmal ein bisschen wasser rein
dann glas hinauf und dann hüpfte oder so
also leute also leute ich habe jetzt mal
wasser eingefüllt das ding ist wirklich
stabil
wieso diese doppel babbel damals kennedy
noch und jetzt können wir erstmal
aufblasen scheiße hier sind ja auch
elektrogeräte vorsichtig
okay das heißt erst kommt ein knoten
nein das konnte ich noch nie gut haben
doch durch hier also ich muss sagen ich
bezweifle dass das erhofft weil ist oder
der platz doch sehe ich wenn ich den
jetzt hier runter schmeiße oder guckt
man auf den fotos wie groß die aussehen
als wenn der so riesig werden kann
das muss ich draußen mal testen leute
lasst mich mal mit dem rum
experimentieren und dann sehen wir uns
unten nochmal ein ich habe ja bei einem
neuen handy akkus weitwinkel ding
eigentlich müsste das aushalten aber hat
er wirklich geil
also das ist an sich ja gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich nehme mal kurz schuhe an am
fuß wieder mal richtig auf ich hoffe
dass ich dann wieder auf kriege h
das problem ist das hat sich jetzt hier
so verheddert deswegen schmeißt sich
nicht einmal aus meinem fenster raus mal
gucken ob wir das aushält das iphone
stelle ich jetzt mal hierhin ist ja eh
wasserfest das ging jetzt schneller als
gedacht ich dachte eigentlich der hält
das aus das waren so zweieinhalb meter
kaputt also ich hätte gerne aufgeblasen
aber leider hat es nicht mehr geklappt
weil ich den vortritt zugezogen habe
leute ich würde sagen dass war es
erstmal mit diesem video es wird auf
jeden fall noch nächsten part geben da
könnt euch darauf freuen abonnieren den
kanal hast du nach oben da und was ich
auch sagen kann es wird demnächst wieder
neue essens videos geben da freue ich
mich schon sehr
deswegen lohnt es sich noch mehr zu
abonnieren schenkt auch mit anderen
kanal habe alex v da gibt es jeden tag
im video cartwright
[Musik]